omeyer l'ordre du jour appelle la
question orale madame esther sittler à
monsieur le ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie
vous avez la parole ma chère collègue
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
madame le ministre je souhaite attirer
enfin c'est plutôt au ministre de
l'écologie que la question s'adresse
attirer votre attention sur la clause de
revoyure prévue dans l'agrément des
libres et aux éco organismes de la
filière de collecte et de recyclage des
emballages ménagers l'article 46 de la
loi numéro 2009 6 967 du 3 août 2009 de
programmation relative à la mise en
oeuvre du grenelle de l'environnement
prévoyez des objectifs ambitieux en
matière de collecte et de recyclage des
déchets à savoir 75% de recyclage et un
financement à 80% du coût des deux
services lors de la signature de
l'agrément délivré à eco emballages
adelphe les modalités de calcul du taux
de prise en charge sous-estimé largement
le coût réel ce qui a conduit l'état a
proposé une clause de revoyure qui
devait intervenir à la mi 2012 et
permettre une revalorisation du
dispositif de soutien financier aux
collectivités dès le 1er janvier 2013
or le 18 décembre 2012 la commission
consultative d'agrément de la filière
emballages 7 opposés aux propositions
faites par le ministère pourriez-vous
par conséquent m'indiquer sous quel
délai la clause de revoyure sera
finalement appliqué et quels en seront
les modalités
merci beaucoup merci monsieur collègues
la parole est à madame la ministre
madame la sénatrice là il me sera plus
facile de vous répondre sur un domaine
qui est pour moi un peu moins technique
que le précédent et qui répondent
effectivement à une priorité que défend
avec force et vigueur le ministre
monsieur martin qui donc n'est pas là au
banc pour vous répondre et qui m'a
demandé qui m'a chargé de dire la
réponse vous l'avez vous l'avez dit
l'intérêt qu'il y avait effectivement à
veiller à ce que les pays d'europe y
veille le pourcentage des déchets
ménagers qui vont en décharge soit
réduit il n'est que de 5% au niveau
européen et on pourcentage alors qu'en
france il est encore de 34%
seuls 35 % en france sont recyclés alors
que l'objectif européen et vous en citer
un chiffre pour la france est de 50% à
l'horizon 2020 la crise économique
actuelle la raréfaction des ressources
ne font qu'accroître l'absolue nécessité
d'aller vers un modèle d'économie
circulaire qui nous fera sortir du tout
jetable
alors cette transition a été acté lors
de la conférence environnementale du
mois de septembre 2013 confirmé à
l'occasion une conférence de mise en
oeuvre de l'économie circulaire
justement le ministre de l'ecologie bien
sûr est particulièrement concerné il m'a
dit de vous le dire avec force par la
clause de revoyure prévue dans
l'agrément des éco organismes de la
filière de collecte et de recyclage des
emballages ménagers agrément qui a plus
de 20 ans d'existence mais qu'il nous
faut faire vivre et qui justifiait
justement qu'il y ait cette clause de
revoyure à l'occasion du renouvellement
de l'agrément de l'éco organisme pour la
période 2011 2016
il avait été décidé de ce nouveau rendez
vous aux fans un au sein de la filière à
la fin 2012 pour réexaminer les
différents points à faire évoluer les
travaux menés en 2012 n'ont pas permis
d'aboutir
vous l'avez relever et on ne peut que le
regretter tous ensemble le ministre a
bien pris en compte le besoin absolu d'y
parvenir
et il entend bien faire en sorte qu'un
arbitrage soit rendue dans les meilleurs
délais possibles c'est la phrase que je
dois vous dire c'est à dire je n'ai pas
de date précise à vous donner
mais philippe martin souhaite qu'ils
permettent de répondre aux besoins des
collectivités d'atteindre les objectifs
de recyclage en préservant l'équilibré
économique des entreprises
contributrices de cette filière je lui
redirai
avec force la question qui a été la
vôtre madame la sénatrice soyez sûr pour
que très vite on puisse mettre en oeuvre
les conclusions de cette nouvelle
convention qui permettra de répondre à
la clause de revoyure dons que vous
appelez de tous vos voeux et qui est une
absolue nécessité
merci madame la ministre madame sittler
merci je vous remercie de cette réponse
et je vous prie de transmettre donc à
monsieur martin que vraiment les
collectivités locales qui s'occupe de la
collecte des ordures ménagères sont très
très intéressé par cette est très motivé
par cette clause de revoyure ça ça y va
de l'équilibré des finances aussi des
collectivités qui s'occupe de cette
collecte est donc l attendent et al
guetteront les les nouvelles qui
viendront du ministère de
l'environnement qui concerneront qui
concerneront cette clause de revoyure
merci beaucoup merci même sittler